why do you think you have low
self-esteem because like like who feel
crush a room and then I was watching the
other night laughing my ass off and you
followed me and he gets off because I
didn't really get him I was like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about yeah you
did yeah you always say that because you
feel yeah I don't know artists don't
feel unless it's like I don't know I
just don't feel like sometimes you
notice one feel that great I guess it's
probably the only thing like I think
like when you don't feel that great
about yourself we were talking about
this one time recently that's kind of
good for a comic like hell yeah you
should I want you to go into that though
well I figured there'd be something oh
yeah I mean I just um you know I don't
know I think growing up I this was super
him you know I just felt you know I just
didn't feel that good you know I just
didn't feel that you know I didn't feel
sure myself I didn't feel that good I
think probably I was young I didn't have
like you know people telling me that
everything was okay you know and if you
don't have that voice ingrained in you
then you just always kind of like you're
on a little bit of like a you know a
teeter totter and you just feel a bit
nervous you know stability
yeah there's no stability kind of inside
me so I think that's why I tried things
like doing steroids or you know getting
in a you know drugs and alcohol or
probably even maybe comedy you know just
searching out for something to make me
feel you know just search an out for
stuff just comedy feel that void at all
or no what comedy makes it so it made us
always in control of everything so if
I'm on the stage I have the microphone I
can control everything goes so if I can
control how everything goes then I can't
leave it up to anybody else to make me
feel bad you know that's interesting it
limits the percentage chances of anybody
making me feel bad so then if I get
really good at what I'm doing and if I
know everybody's laugh and then they
couldn't not like me you know like they
couldn't you can't laugh and [ __ ]
hate somebody at the same time it's hard
I mean maybe that's why I do it to have
to be a wizard really to do that just
figure that out that's interesting so I
think if I can make people laugh then
I'll be like okay I don't have to worry
for a second everybody I'm okay no
everybody feels like I'm okay and
there's ever a time when you're content
you're always just yeah when I kill it
usually then I know it right after yeah
when I feel
good but now it's getting better man I
mean I go to like now I'm an adult I go
to therapy and do all that kind of stuff
to try and you know battle that inner
[ __ ] so I don't you know go to therapy
humming therapy one time a week just
once
yeah for an hour yep one hour this lady
Joanie do they figure anything out is it
more you just talking to them no this
lady's pretty good man you know I go for
like adult sex therapy or something you
know when they talk about sex and they
talk about you know like you're an
addict no dude I like I don't even
really care about sex that much like I
think sex is kind of born like you're
banging each other for [ __ ] eight
minutes and then you know everybody's
just kind of laying it sitting around
the room you know it's it's kind of like
a [ __ ] bad fight after you're done oh
I'm over hey because you're a handsome
dude and popular dude so you know ladies
yeah but like you could go the John Muir
route where he said so much sex he's
like [ __ ] it and start doing dudes
really that's true about John Mayer it
is now dude it is now is it have you
added a view is that are you saying that
you've had orgies and you've been and I
mean up in it I was involved with a
couple of girls that were cousins one
time in Indiana actually and then you
kind of learn I think every cousins they
are now dude I'll say that brother at
least you're definitely tied together
[Laughter]
that's kind of like it's like you just
got you just fought everybody out of
breath and just tired like all right
what now I guess bar clothes back on and
maybe drink some [ __ ] iced tea would
you talk that there's therapists about
sex but if you don't care about it with
that part of it it's like you gotta care
about stuff so it just makes you wonder
like I just like to start thinking about
why feel certain or just start like
trying to figure out what I feel you
know trying to figure out do they always
I feel like and I haven't seen a
therapist talk about this but don't they
just chalk it up to your childhood
yeah a lot of times every time yeah a
lot well a lot of times but then you
just tell the stories like a challenge
egg thank you I'll see you next week
cool our again excuse your shitty father
well that's a problem they can get in
your head like like but it's true it's
worth it
sometimes they can man I mean this one
kinda helps me think about stuff
sometimes I overthink things but I don't
know I like to try and get involved in
why I'm feeling a certain way as you
know it's good to navigate it yeah and
talk it out to have someone who's not
but you know biased or yeah what
sometimes they can be biased oh and they
can't help it like I went to a couples
therapist that's different yeah because
the guy said to me to try to figure me
out and he goes he goes so what do you
how'd you well I went to boarding school
when I was 14 and he goes all your
parents threw you away Wow and I was
like hey man I don't don't say it like
that
cameras emotional Wow
I could see you in a recycling bin dude
that's crazy your parents threw you away
no a floating down the river so when he
finds a recycling bin in here in there
you're just [ __ ] lifting weights down
there there's banana you have any
problems with depression or anything
yeah most I had a lot of problem with
that growing up but now I don't have
them as much anymore you know cuz of
medication or bns on medication I take
low-dose medication and then you know
I'm just more like I think confident now
these days you know just getting and
also figuring that [ __ ] out you know
like I'm a big proponent if I feel a
certain way I want to try and figure out
why do I feel that way you know so it's
kind of fun it's a journey you know it's
just like train and it's like you know
you have to go you know like you know
you have to start to figure it out you
know and the more you do it the easier
it gets you know but anyway do you find
any success in it though yeah really I
am yeah I'm finding awesome so it makes
me want to do it yeah like yeah yeah
just like yeah man I wish I could give
like a you know real concrete example
but does it make you more aware of like
why you feel so yeah like one more aware
of triggers and things yeah a hundred
percent and it makes it so that you know
like the other day like I was hanging
out this girl I could tell she wanted me
to say like this she was pretty right
like not enough way she was asking for
it for some sort of like got you know
like looking to feel good she just was
kind of feeling unsure about herself and
all I had to say was like you know I
think you're you know pretty just
something he was looking for something
light like some sort of yeah
confirmation right and just
as a human being I should have said it's
what a nice person yes a hundred percent
and I'm a nice guy could it you know but
something in Sodom is like man if you
say that then it's like part of your
giving some a weakness there's some
weakness there I was afraid to say it I
could feel like I was afraid not like I
didn't want to to make her feel bad but
just like man if I say this then this
shows ganar over you or something or
she's gonna know that I care you know or
that I'm sort of care and then if I care
then she's got that over you yeah and
then I means I'm a caring person and so
all these things that maybe are built in
the back of my head where I'll just care
about myself now I start to care about
other people what's how's that gonna
feel inside of me Wow so just weird [ __ ]
like that but it starts to kind of
figure it out this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]